hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
you're here for the q a video for idea
number 23 which was criticality and
complexity where we talked about
how the world which is governed by very
simple underlying laws with just a few
basic ingredients
can nevertheless become very complicated
looking complicated
looking structures can arise in it and i
think that most of the questions fall
into sort of
one or two themes one of two different
themes so i'm basically going to
concentrate on those two
themes one of them is the relationship
between complexity and entropy
there is a relationship but it's not
clear what it is so this is a good sort
of research level
connection the other is if you have one
of these power
law distributions right if you have some
a number of things
as a function of size or whatever and
the number of things goes as
the size to some power there are
mathematical technicalities
associated with this like what do you do
at very very very small sizes
very very large sizes how do you
calculate the average and stuff like
that so i'm going to go into some of
those technicalities it's not going to
be like super duper highly technical
but it's important because it has to do
with how the ideas that we talked about
in the last video
relate to the real world and i think
that the real world is important so
that's what we'll talk about so but
first let's go into
uh complexity and entropy i'm tempted to
say
complexity versus entropy so why not say
it
why would i put it that way well the
general idea you should have in your
mind
is that entropy which counts how many
micro states correspond to a given
macroscopically observable phenomenon in
the boltzmann way of talking about it
those of you who are new here we had a
whole biggest ideas video on
entropy it increases in closed systems
right the universe becomes higher and
higher
entropy and roughly speaking high
entropy
is boring high entropy is simple in some
very definable sense if you have a box
of gas
then you let the gas equilibrate it's
just going to be perfectly smooth it's
going to be the same
everywhere in the box if you have the
universe with gravity
things are more complicated okay but if
you wait long enough
if you wait to the far far future of the
universe the equivalent
of that equilibration of a box of gas is
that the universe empties out
uh in a universe with a positive vacuum
energy like ours
seems to have the stuff that we have in
the universe that makes it interesting
stars planets galaxies eventually
disperses away
and almost every region of the universe
almost every observable universe size
region is just
empty so once again very very simple
so if you think of simplicity as the
opposite of complexity
then the general tendency of the second
law of thermodynamics which is to
increase
entropy should be to fight against
complexity in some way
so you might want to know why is there
complex stuff in the universe
if the general tendency is just for
entropy to be increasing and entropy
makes things uh
sort of just dissipate and be simple and
not complex at all
so there are two two sub ideas here that
i want to get into
um one is do power laws
power law distributions um and i'm gonna
not worry about the details of power law
versus law normal or something like that
in fact let's say
let's make it explicit that we're not
worried about power laws what we're
worried about is
scale-free behavior so do scale-free
distributions
of something we're not even going to go
into what we're distributing
somehow maximize entropy
in some sense somehow
because clearly not in a very general
sense but we'll
uh getting to have a sense of which they
might possibly okay so
remember we talked about the fact that
even if we don't agree
on the once and for all definition of
complexity we have this feeling that
things that we would recognize and
identify as complex
have the feature that something is going
on on small scales and intermediate
scales and large scales okay
it's not just the same thing over and
over again it's not just
one scale one sort of level of
interestingness
repeated over and over again that's not
very complex right that's not very
complicated that's just kind of simple
in its own way
so complex structures or organisms or
systems
have things going on at all scales now a
power law distribution is an example
of that but we also mentioned that there
are things like log normal distributions
and there are other distributions
that do a pretty good approximation of
being scale-free over a certain regime
so that's what we're asking about those
does a distribution
so by distribution let's uh change
variables once again
uh change symbols so let's say f of
x okay it's our distribution by the
reason why we're
changing the symbols from what we did in
the original video is i'm not specific
about what we're talking about this
could be a number
as a function of size or frequency as a
function of rank but at some
likelihood or number of times something
happens versus some parameter that tells
you about the scale of that system in a
very very general system
sense and we're saying that f of x is
given by or at least proportional to
x to some power uh minus
n okay so we called alpha the power last
time we're going to call it n this time
just because
n is a little bit less intimidating
right so it's a
latin letter uh rather than greek there
you go most of us use the latin alphabet
so if you have this kind of thing what
does that look like
on a let's do it this way on a regular
plot
a linear plot we have f of x
versus x and it's going to go like this
if you have a positive n
so you have 1 over x to some positive
power or x to some negative power
equivalently
and on a log log plot you have
log of f versus log of x
and then it's going to look like a
straight line with a downward slope okay
and you know remember i did say that
almost all the plots we were going to do
in the last video were log log plots and
yet when i plotted uh
i didn't plot but i showed a plot of
walking speed versus
size of cities and some people said i
don't understand like how you could walk
with a negative speed
because they forgot that it's on a log
log plot remember what log
looks like if you have just some
variable x and you take the log of x
at one at x equals one the log equals
zero
at x equals between zero and one
log goes like this and for positive
numbers log goes like this
okay so the logarithm goes from minus
infinity to infinity
as x goes from zero to plus infinity so
for x between zero and one the logarithm
is a negative number even though x is a
positive number
so when you saw negative walking speeds
you were really looking at negative
logs of walking speeds in some units all
right anyway
so these are distributions and we talked
in the entropy video about the entropy
of a distribution so
the entropy uh in some sense i'm not
going to go into whose
sense it is gibbs or boltzmann or
shannon or something like that
but the entropy can be written as minus
the integral
of f of x times the log of f
x this is the entropy of the
distribution
f for some distribution so s of
f uh integrated over dx
so this says take the distribution
multiply it by its log
integrate that take the minus sign why
the minus sign because
f is often going to be less than minus
one uh less than one rather so this is
this thing in the integral is often
going to be negative so to get a
positive entropy you want that
minus sign there uh in particular
remember if you think of
f as a probability distribution if
that's what it is
then the probability of some discrete
event is always less than one or equal
to one at most right so
this is generically this thing in the
integral is generically going to be
negative
multiplied by a minus sign to get a
positive entropy okay
and we said so you might want to say
well think of this you know we just said
f of x is proportional to x to the minus
n um we didn't normalize it to normalize
a function or a distribution means to
divide by some constant number
so that the integral of the whole thing
becomes equal to one
right you want the total probability if
that's what you're measuring to be equal
to one
or you can normalize it to some other
thing if you're if you're talking about
the
number of people in a city then you want
to normalize to the total population of
whatever system you're looking at
okay but we didn't do that here we just
said f of x is proportional to minus n
so you might want to
normalize it or something like that then
you could plug into this
and then you might ask well is is there
some sense
in which these distributions these power
law distributions
are high entropy or low entropy or what
is the relationship between them
so remember that we also said for
different kinds of distributions let's
say that we have a distribution that can
only go
from you know 0 to some x max
okay then here's f of x
and this is not the power law
distributions now we're just talking
about let's imagine we have a
distribution
and we said that if you have a peaked
distribution like this
okay this would be low entropy
this would be something where just by
knowing the
distribution you know a lot about the
system there's some maximum value here
for f
x and probably the value of x in the
actual system is very very close to that
because it's strongly peaked around that
that's low entropy you know a lot about
the system just by knowing the
distribution
whereas if you have a distribution like
this that is more or less
flat everywhere that's a high entropy
distribution okay
high entropy means you don't know just
from knowing the distribution
where exactly x is you don't have a lot
of information about that
so okay what about these power laws well
i mean it doesn't look high entropy at
all right the power law
kind of looks peaked at x equals zero or
something like that
you should you should be thinking about
this plot right here
in in regular uh plotting space um
so it certainly doesn't look like high
entropy so your your initial
idea which is fine is to say look if you
have a system
that is in a power law distribution of
what's going on
inside then clearly it is not maximizing
its entropy
clearly it could be an even higher
entropy right because high entropy
distributions are
flat um but that's that's true as far as
it goes but there is a caveat there
which is that very very often
we have systems that are not closed
right that are interacting with the rest
of the world
and that means and this is very very
complicated like if you have a
closed system it's simple about to know
what to do if you have an
open system there are many ways to be
open there's only one way to be closed
or isolated there are many many ways to
interact with the rest of the world okay
so for example imagine a system
in a heat bath
and we talked about this so we talked
about entropy etc
so you imagine that physically here's
some big box and here's your little box
with your system
and the big box is you know some
photons or some gas or whatever at
temperature
t capital t okay and then
what happens is your system is allowed
to exchange energy with the heat bath
that it's in so it's not closed it can
fluctuate slightly upward or downward in
energy
okay it's still if you let the system
evolve
it still reaches an equilibrium
distribution
and you might think well it's a maximum
entropy distribution that's what
equilibrium means
but it is not this flat distribution the
distribution it reaches is the maxwell
boltzmann
maxwell boltzmann distribution
and it looks like this i'm not going to
give you the actual formula but it looks
like that okay so here's f
as a function of x where x in this case
is you know the momentum or the energy
in fact
it's the energy for the maxwell
boltzmann distribution so
in what sense is that maxwell-boltzmann
distribution
high entropy like that's clearly not
flat
it clearly does not maximize this actual
entropy
formula i can if i had a distribution
that just looked like that
it would have a higher entropy than the
maxwell-boltzmann distribution has
so what is going on what's going on is
that the maxwell-boltzmann distribution
maximizes entropy
s the entropy given
that the average energy of a
molecule or atom or whatever is in the
system you're talking about
is given by the temperature okay
so this is a feature of this kind of
system that can interact with the
outside world
uh it doesn't make sense to just say
well there's some initial conditions
inside we let them go
and we don't talk about the interaction
with the rest of the world the rest of
the world can
either put energy in or take energy out
and is continuously doing so
so there's a constraint that you're at
constant temperature
right and i'm gonna different systems
have different you know proportionality
factors of a half or a third here
whatever but it depends on how you
measure
but the basic point is that in the box
the
average temperature is going to be the
average energy is going to be given by
the temperature roughly speaking
but that allows for fluctuations around
that the total energy inside the box can
go upside
up and down and so what you want to do
is just not maximize the entropy inside
the box full stop
you want to maximize the entropy of the
box subject to the constraint
that the average energy is given by a
fixed number
and that gives you the maxwell boltzmann
distribution it's
very possible that either maxwell or
boltzmann actually derive the
distribution this way probably boltzmann
but
i'm not sure about that the point is
that once you start saying
subject to a certain constraint i'm
going to maximize the entropy
then you can get distributions that are
not flat and yet are in some sense
maximizing the entropy
and the maxwell-boltzmann distribution
does that so
you can ask yourself um does
f x that's a terrible f isn't it
uh i'm getting too excited by
statistical mechanics
does f of x proportional to x to the
minus n
maximize the entropy
subject to some constraint
and if so what kind of constraint is it
and the answer is i'm not really sure
or rather the answer is yes you can
invent constraints
such that when you maximize the entropy
of a distribution subject to those
constraints you get a power law
okay that is a true statement what is
not clear
certainly to me and i don't think to
anybody is
uh are the kinds of constraints that you
can choose to make that happen
relevant to the systems that you're
actually thinking about remember this is
what
this is i tried to make this a theme of
the complexity video itself that
it's one thing to show that a
distribution has a certain form
okay it's a completely other thing to
understand the physical mechanism behind
that kind of form and so if you just
want to know
if you have this target in mind ahead of
time i want to get a power log because i
see power laws in nature a lot
and i think that systems try to maximize
their entropy
which by the way i mean they do and i'm
not trying to downplay that
um the philosophy here the physical
intuition that we're working on
is that given some constraints if you
know what's happening in terms of the
exchange of information or heat or
whatever
between an open system and its
environment
given those constraints it's perfectly
natural to think that the system will
work to maximize
its entropy the point is however that
there can be more than one way
to actually put on such constraints and
you know i i
this is the homework that i did for this
q a video i googled it you know you know
maximize entropy with power law
distribution i've done this before in my
life but i've sort of forgotten the
results because the results are
there are different papers claiming that
if i
put on this constraint or that
constraint or this other constraint
i can maximize entropy and get a power
law distribution it is
so there's two possibilities for what's
going on here one possibility is that in
the real world
when you see power law distributions
they are maximum entropy
for completely different reasons right
like different power laws might be
uh having you know taking this temporary
equilibrium form
of a power law that let me say that more
accurately
it might temporarily be true that for a
certain open system
its equilibrium form is a power law
rather than maxwell boltzmann or just
flat
and for another system it's for a
completely different reason right and
that's completely possible
the other possibility is that there's
something deeper that we don't
know or that we haven't been pointed or
at least that i have not been able to
figure out or or
find which makes it all universal right
which says
that um there here's the reason why you
over and over again get these complex
uh power law structures i'm skeptical
about the latter just because you know
you don't always get power law
distributions you get log normals you
get other things like that and so you
don't want your
purported grand explanation to be too
good that it rules out the possibility
of other things that we actually observe
in nature sometimes
so i like the idea of
saying that for this or that system uh
we ask you know why does it have this
power law form and we provide an
explanation
not so it's a different kind of
explanation than what we had before
what we were talking about before in the
original video were
generative models right you start with a
distribution and then you act on it in
some time evolving kind of way
like a preferential attachment model
where people have a certain probability
of going to a certain city or something
like that
and then you generate a final
distribution by doing that over and over
again
okay this is a whole different
philosophy of generating a distribution
this is saying
i have a system i let it equilibrate
subject to some external constraints and
i find that it ends up in a power law
okay different words than the something
like the generative models would have
but maybe there is underlying systematic
uh things that make those two things
match up in the right circumstances all
i'm saying is that i don't know
right now and i'm not sure it's known i
suspect that the
you know landscape of complexity is
complex and you shouldn't be overly
eager to say that every single complex
system
uh has the same origin uh for its
structure on all scales but i mean i'd
be happy to be wrong about that i'm sure
there's also some
universality in some of the features we
just don't know what they are
um did i say everything oh yeah the
other thing i wanted to say about that
was
um there's another consideration
that again i'm not going to be very
helpful about to clarify
there's the idea that you maximize
entropy
versus entropy production
okay so remember we're dealing with open
systems now
so a living being or
an ecosystem or a computer they generate
heat
right your laptop gets hot if you put it
on your lap despite the fact that it's
called laptop
why because it's doing calculations it's
generating heat
it is increasing the entropy of the
universe it is producing entropy
okay so another way of asking this
question
is not you know maybe the principle the
dynamical principle that is going on
is not the system maximizes its entropy
but that it either maximizes or
minimizes depending on the circumstances
it's entropy production and so maybe
you know in the right circumstances uh
either we're talking about a complex
system that wants to be efficient like a
biological organism right that you know
evolution
uh guides us in directions where we use
the energy that we take in
in the most possible efficient way and
you might interpret that as
minimizing the entropy production rate
or conversely you might say well there's
different channels for different
reactions to go through
and entropy wants to increase so if you
can find a channel
for a reaction to happen in that
maximizes the entropy production and
that's favored for some reason right
so all this you know you see why this is
complicated if you if you
again go again go and google maximum
entropy principles
uh one of the things you will find is
there are also minimum entropy
principles
and the whole i'm not a super duper
expert here so i think there are experts
who have strong opinions but i gather
their opinions don't agree with each
other
about the best way of thinking about
these different things which is again
a reflection of the fact that the whole
field is a little bit pre-paradigmatic
we haven't yet decided what are the
spherical cows that we should focus on
in this game okay so that's one thing i
wanted to say about complexity versus
entropy do complex systems in some sense
maximize the entropy
uh the answer is maybe in fact i would
go so far say the answer is probably but
it's still a lot of work to figure out
in what sense that actually is what are
the constraints you have to put on the
system
to make that happen the other question
is again this is still under the rubric
of complexity versus entropy
the other question is how why do complex
structures
let's say does does complexity
of uh evolve
and i don't mean evolve over time once
it's complex but how do they come to
exist in the first place
again this is related to the fact that
if second law of thermodynamics uh
is true everything is just increasing
entropy then why in the world do you
stop along the way to be a complex
structure
this is a relative of the creationist
argument against evolution
right that says the second law of
thermodynamics just says
entropy is increasing yet we have all
this wonderfully complex
biosphere on earth you violated the laws
of physics if you believe in evolution
so there's two answers to that uh
argument
one is that's a very bad argument
because the biosphere is not a closed
system right
entropy only increases in closed systems
it doesn't necessarily increase in
open systems otherwise you could not put
champagne in your refrigerator and cool
it off
and that's usually the answer that's
given and by itself that's perfectly
good
but that doesn't actually say why it is
true
that the complex structures do arise
what that argument says is that
it doesn't violate any laws of physics
for complex structures to arise in the
ecosystem
but it doesn't say therefore they will
just as it doesn't violate laws of
physics
you might ask for more than that right
you might say well
why i mean is it necessarily true that
complex structures would arise or is it
likely or is it was it a rare fluke or
what's going on here in something like
the biosphere okay
so for this again i'm going to beg your
indulgence because
i've actually written a paper about this
and i want to tell you about what was in
that paper
you know again i do this all the time
but it's my video series so of course
i'm going to tell you about my papers
not just because i think my papers are
the best but because
they're the i try to answer the
questions i'm interested in right and so
those are going to appear in the
videos um so how and why does complexity
evolve
uh is a is a question i addressed in a
paper with scott aronson
lauren willett who has the same last
name but it's not related to my wife
jennifer willett
um and so we published a paper and
actually it was
people pointed out a couple of people
pointed out that we made a mistake and
so we fixed it and so
this is very embarrassing and so this is
why i love all you folks so i'm telling
you this embarrassing fact it's been
years and we have still not submitted
the revised version
of the paper to the archive uh we have a
revised version that is correct and it's
still not
in the public domain i'm sorry about
that but i hope to get it there uh
quickly uh
brett burness is one of the people a
postdoc who helped us figure this out
and i'll explain
to you uh what i mean here is the paper
that we wrote we examined
the famous example of a cup of coffee
okay so i haven't planned out um how to
best
uh draw this but anyway
the here's the cup and what we imagine
is that here
yeah let me see can i do this here we
have
cream and there we have coffee
okay so this is the cream and we layer
it on the top
and you have coffee on the bottom
and this is a low entropy configuration
okay and but if you stir it the entropy
goes up now stirring it is not
quite fair because you're then it's not
a closed system anymore but we're going
to ignore all those
um that's not the issue that we're
dealing with here today we're dealing
with a slightly different issue
what we know is that if you let time go
by
okay and you do stir it with a spoon
then what you will get
is oops gotta draw my cup in a
consistent way here here's my coffee cup
and let me make this cream here a little
bit brighter
because it's thicker okay
look at this getting good and then over
here
when everything is mixed together
we have cream coffee all mixed together
okay
so this is clearly low entropy
all the creams on the top all the
coffees on the bottom
segregated here once everything's mixed
together it is clearly
high entropy
but you notice that there's no
complexity anywhere here in these
pictures that i've drawn if you just
again don't worry
too much about the detailed definition
of complexity and you just look at the
pictures
uh this is simple all the creams on the
top all the coffees in the bottom that's
all the information you need to know so
you're tempted and it's okay to use a
sort of kolmogorov definition of
complexity rather remember the komolgov
complexity
uh had to do with the shortest algorithm
that you would need to write to
print out a number so if you think of
the cream and the coffee as an
image like you know pixelate it and make
a file a jpeg on your computer
um could you make a computer program
to print out the pixels of this image
well yeah you just print out a whole
bunch of white pixels and a whole bunch
of black pixels that's it it's very
simple short program
likewise over here in the high entropy
state it is also simple
you just print out a whole bunch of gray
pixels or brown pixels or whatever it is
they're all
mixed together okay so there is clearly
and again we haven't defined exactly
what we mean by entropy in this sense
yet but in this sort of casual i know it
when i see it sense
it is clear there is no strict
relationship
between entropy and complexity right
here you can have very low entropy and
also low complexity high simplicity if
complexity is the opposite of simplicity
but you can also have very high entropy
and be simple okay
so one of the mistakes that the
creationists make is to conflate
low entropy with high complexity that's
not exactly
the same thing very very very low
entropy is always simple
and very very very high entropy is
always simple
what's interesting is in between okay so
if i move this little arrow
down actually move it up a little bit um
and then
imagine that i actually took a snapshot
while i was stirring
the cream into the coffee okay well then
i wonder how clever i can be about this
[Music]
probably medium clever so
then you know you have some cream at the
top but it also sort of gets
mixed in a little bit right and you
begin to see
this is the a step along the way
when you're stirring the cream into the
coffee right you see swirls and tendrils
uh you know things that look like
galaxies in the coffee cup right if
you're
astronomically inclined so
this is medium entropy
and again by the standards of well i
just look at it
and i ask myself you know how long would
the description be if i tried to
describe it
this is complex in fact you could
kind of imagine that there is structure
on all different scales inside that
coffee cup there's tiny little swirls
there's big swirls etc on both the sides
of
low entropy and high entropy there was
not structure on all scales right it was
very
homogeneous over large scales but here
there's something going on at all
different scales
it looks complex so what this means
is that there is not a monotonic
relationship between entropy and
complexity
so if you think about entropy
going up and complexity so imagine this
is complex
and this is simple okay
then what you get is a curve like this
that complexity can
get big when entropy is medium-sized and
you can actually show
that when entropy is very very low it's
always going to be simple when entropy
is very very high it's always going to
be simple
so it's possible it's allowed for
entropy to go up
when you're on the sorry for complexity
to go up when you're on the road from
low entropy to high energy but it's not
necessary this would also be an allowed
curve or this would be an allowed curve
right these are all different ways that
entropy and complexity can be related
jim crutchfield who's a complexity
scientist at uc davis
has referred to this curve entropy
versus complexity as something that is
rediscovered every five years
so scott and lauren and bret and i
rediscovered it once again
but what we did what that was a little
bit different is that we plotted it
versus time
okay so if you if this is just the
general
formula or general behavior of
complexity versus entropy
well you know that there is a monotonic
relationship between entropy and time
that's called the second law of
thermodynamics right so entropy just
goes up like this
whereas complexity can go up and then go
down
okay so this is a more
slightly more sophisticated response
to the creationist critique about
evolution versus the second law of
thermodynamics
not only is it completely
okay for complex structures to evolve as
entropy is increasing but in some very
natural sense
you need for entropy to be increasing if
you want to make
complex structures that's when complex
structures happen
when you're out of equilibrium when you
have the second law of thermodynamics
when entropy can be increasing if you
think back up here
uh at these systems that are open
exchanging
uh information or even matter with their
environment
if you think about the the models that
we talked about where people
actually enter cities or leave them or
there's a sand pile and you're dripping
new greens of sand onto the pile all of
these are out of equilibrium
systems that's a fundamental fact about
them so
it's sort of the the creationists have
it exactly backwards
you need entropy to be increasing to get
and to maintain
these complex structures okay but this
doesn't still
doesn't quite say that they do happen i
mean that's the
lesson of these different curves here
that complexity is allowed
to evolve but it doesn't necessarily so
the other thing to say by the way is
that
this is not just cream and coffee i gave
you that example
and what we did in our little computer
simulations is a sort of cellular
automaton
model for cream and coffee mixing
together the coffee automaton we called
it
but other systems have exactly this
behavior think about the entire universe
right when we did the cosmology video we
talked about the fact that the early
universe was a very simple place it was
hot and dense and smooth
that's all you need to know that's the
comolgrav uh complexity shortest
algorithm hot dense smooth
rapidly expanding there you go that's
the universe the late universe
very very simple right cold dilute
still smooth okay that's the very late
universe still very very simple it's
now it's now at the intermediate stage
of the history of the universe where
things are lumpy
and changing dynamically and something
something is happening on all
different scales now is when the
universe is complex in some very
definite way
okay so the universe obeys this kind of
going up and going down
um plot here of complexity over time
so that's a nice thing to keep in mind
okay
so but we did you know we didn't just
state these things we tried to quantify
it you know
you know look this is one of those cases
where honestly
this is most of the content you know
these pictures and once you see it
everyone goes oh yeah okay sure that
makes sense
um but uh here's a little inside scoop
on how science works
you can't just write up a page or two
pages and draw these pictures and submit
it to a journal and say you know publish
me like no one would care
people would say come on that is not
enough you have not there's something in
science called the least publishable
unit
or something in academia more generally
like you have to do a certain amount of
work
but a certain amount of effort into it
to actually get something published
and getting published papers is the
currency of the realm in academia so
we wanted to say like okay what could we
say about this could we make
derive theorems about it or get some
numerical results or what could we show
so we did these little computer
simulations um of cream
mixing into coffee and there's so one
thing we
hit automatically is you want to plot
complexity versus time
entropy versus time is easy that that
you can calculate but you need a formula
for complexity right and that's exactly
what i've been saying
i'm not going to tell you the formula
because we don't have a formula right so
if you want to plot it you need a
formula so what do we mean by complexity
in this case we invented something
called the apparent
complexity so first let me remind you of
the comol girl complexity
i hope i'm spelling his name correctly
kamal grove complexity is the shortest
algorithm
i'm not going to write the whole thing
but it's the shortest algorithm
that will print out the system the
string or whatever that you're
interested in
um so we have that because we have an
image
of where the cream is where the coffee
is despite calling it a coffee cup we
did a two-dimensional
automaton so really literally it's just
a two-dimensional image
so the shortest algorithm that will
print out the jpeg file that will make
that
image okay here's a problem here's a
cute little problem about using the
kamal grove complexity there's two
problems
problem one is that uh it doesn't
actually capture what you care about
because
if you think about it remember this is
exactly the
problem that we had um that i mentioned
about the comal growth complexity in the
case of strings
is that a random string is super duper
complex
in the comal girl of complexity so if
you have
if you have this kind of thing over here
where you have all the
um coffee molecules and cream molecules
are exactly equally distributed
then you know it would be very low
combograph complexity
but if you had tiny fluctuations right
if you typically had from one pixel to
another
a completely different value then your
chemical can actually be huge because
you need to specify every single pixel
right so that's a little bit not exactly
what we want you know we want something
where
a random number counts as low complexity
right a truly random image you know just
random
amounts of little tiny pixels uh
should be kind of a white noise thing
but we want to sort of average over
a certain size right like we can't see
every individual atom in the coffee and
the cream so in some sense we want to
coarse grain and
therefore we invented something called
the
apparent complexity
the apparent complexity that we invented
is basically just the
coarse-grained comal growth complexity
so what that means is we take this image
that we have of cream mixing into coffee
we average over a certain you know size
of a certain number of pixels
and then we ask about the komodo of
complexity of that to within some
error bars or something like that so in
that case if you have something which is
just random numbers
they will all average out central limit
theorem right and therefore we get a low
kamalgrove complexity so
indeed we checked the apparent
complexity for
images like this is low for cream and
coffee being completely separate
high for them being completely mixed
together sorry
low for being completely mixed together
and high for the swirls and all that
stuff the other problem with kamalgarh
complexity
is that it's uncomputable
and this is not actually um relevant to
anything
that we're talking about in complexity
but it's a cute fact that maybe you
should know
um you literally in principle cannot
calculate
the kamal growth complexity of a string
if someone hands you a string
if someone has you an algorithm then you
can figure out how long the algorithm is
but if someone says what is here's a
string or here's an image
what is the shortest algorithm that can
print it out
you don't know you can never know and
why well it's because of the halting
problem essentially i'm not going to go
into this
but there's a known problem in computer
science alan turing showed
that if you ask the following question
given a computer program
okay um can you tell me whether it will
ever halt
ever stop running or not right you know
that if you ever done any computer
programming
there is the infinite loop problem you
can just get caught in a loop and
cycle around over and over and over
again okay and that's bad
so you might think that you should just
be able to look at a computer program
and if you're a very very good
programmer you should be able to notice
whether there is an infinite loop stuck
in there somewhere or not
so um turing
proved that in principle in general
you cannot ever do that and the way that
he proved it is basically
he was able to find a way of essentially
writing a computer program so
if you have one algorithm that will
answer whether another algorithm halts
or not okay
then he figured out a way to make the
other algorithm essentially say
okay if this other algorithm says i'm
going to halt then i'm not going to halt
and if it says i am going to halt then i
won't okay
so it's very much in the spirit of
girdle's incompleteness theorem kurt
gerdel managed to write
a statement in mathematical number
theory that was equivalent to saying
i cannot be proven true and then if you
can prove it true
your system is in uh inconsistent and if
you can't prove it true then there are
true statements that cannot be proven
so this is a program that can't be
evaluated for whether or not it halts
according to touring
and the commonwealth complexity well how
would you try to evaluate it
if someone gives you an image and says
okay find the shortest algorithm that
will do that you might say well
i'm just going to keep making up
algorithms from the
shortest algorithm i can write to the
long until i get to the point where
i know that i can output that image the
problem is
you might hit an algorithm where you
can't know whether it halts or not
before you get to the algorithm that
prints out your image so
rough again very roughly speaking i hope
the mathematicians and complexity
theories forgive me but anyway
you can't compute the common growth
complexity and principle what you can do
it can be estimated
so you can get a very good approximate
value for the kamal growth complexity
and uh the reason why i mentioned this
really is just because it's funny
how do you figure out the kamalgrove
complexity of something
well you know we have algorithms that
take images like these
and try to compress them right in fact
in other words
we essentially have tried to
approximate the action of given
an image find the shortest algorithm
that will print it out
right those are called compression
algorithms so when i say
imagine the jpeg file on your computer
they
the jpeg is an algorithm that given an
image
tries to shrink it down to the small
size that it possibly can then still
uh sort of faithfully reproduce it
and so if you want to know if you have a
computer algorithm
you know automaton that models cream and
coffee mixing into each other
and you want to know given the final
result or given some intermediate result
like this one
so you know here you have an image how
complex is it
okay you just actually
put it into jpeg as a file and you ask
how big file size is
that's the that's the apparent
complexity estimator that we
can use and we did use and it works very
well we tested that it works very well
okay that's just cute and fun so what
are the results what
do i mean by the results i mean we built
a computer program
that models by little pixels
cream and coffee and then has some
dynamics where the cream and the coffee
can mix together
and we let it mix all the way until it
was all mixed together
and then in this way we estimated the
apparent complexity
of the images along the way and we
plotted them
okay and what we find is actually kind
of really interesting
what we find is the results
um and this i think this is new as far
as i know because even though people
have known about these curves before
they haven't really worried about the
time evolution
of them so the question is what kind of
dynamics
gives rise to complexity so what is the
difference between the dynamics that
gives rise to oops
to this kind of curve that goes way up
and way down
versus this kind of curve that just
remains low
and so we you know what we did was we
said well what if just
the cream and coffee move independently
they don't even talk to each other
okay then you would expect they just
diffuse gradually into each other and
you shouldn't get a lot of complexity
and we verified
that's true you don't get a lot of
complexity if the cream and coffee are
moving independently
then we said okay let's imagine that
randomly different cream and coffee
molecules can switch places
if they're nearest neighbors they can
just sort of switch back and forth to
each other
then eventually they will mix together
and we we hoped and we actually
said in the original incorrect version
of our paper that complexity does
develop in that case but then we later
realized we were wrong
and what's going on we were actually
able to show um
or as brett was able to show that the
local interactions never give rise to
complexity
so local
interactions
don't produce complexity
by which i mean if you have you sort of
imagine
zooming in in this figure and imagine
that you have interactions that just
take you know one pixel here and one
pixel there
and let them flip or let them not flip
or whatever nothing like that
ever gives rise to complex structure in
the coffee cup
automaton um and then we were depressed
for a little while but then we worked
harder
and we found that interactions
with lauren long scale
i guess yeah long scale
correlations
do produce complexity
so rather than just letting one little
pixel and one other little pixel switch
what we said was if you could sort of
coherently
have an arbitrary sized box that
moves as one so you say that you you
pick a random size box
here's a random sized box and it
randomly shifts either up down or left
right or whatever
we call that the tectonic model okay
that does
give rise to complexity and just to show
you the results i'm going to try this
again
importing a picture see if this works
so this is uh one of the results we got
so you see that the this is uh
complexity up here
our apparent complexity versus time time
steps so the red
is this diffusive model where the cream
and coffee don't even notice each other
the blue the tectonic model is where
there are these coherent shifts
of blocks of different size and then
this is the complexity you see the
complex structure does evolve like a
fractal-like distribution
power law kind of distribution for the
cream and the coffee
evolves and then it goes away okay so
i think that there's a lesson here i
think this is just like a tiny little
beginning
of a bigger project the lesson is that
the
kinds of dynamical interactions that
give rise to complexity
have to themselves operate on
long scales right it can't just be
individual nearest neighbor kind of
things
that's perfectly plausible in the real
world we have you know gravity
and electromagnetism both of which act
over very large
time scales there are subtleties and
footnotes there like you can
act individually over very small
distances but then if you carry
information a long way and act somewhere
else that might count
just as well right so it's not quite a
theorem that says you need long-range
interactions
but you need information to be shared
over large regions in order for
complexity to
arise um that's not quite a theorem
either
i wish it were a theorem that would be a
nice thing to make more
uh general but anyway this was all a
very very long-winded way of saying
that you
should not be surprised that in the
process of
entropy increasing in the universe
complex structures
arise the laws of physics given the laws
of physics and the fact that the early
universe had low entropy
to show to say that complex structures
happen
very naturally without any planning
without any arrangement
um is the most natural thing in the
world now these are like really simple
dumb complex structures literally just
a complicated looking picture of cream
and coffee coming together
but you could imagine very
straightforwardly that more
interesting structures follow the same
pattern of course there's one pattern
there's one structure everyone cares
about which is
life right what we'd like to know is if
the origin of life
is somehow connected to this story if
the
fact that uh somewhere three and a half
billion years ago
on the earth certain complex chemical
reactions came together
in the right way to form the beginnings
of life
what is the connection of that fact to
these these statements about
uh entropy and complexity and long-range
interactions and
power laws and all these things many of
us believe there is a connection
i think the connection is still very
obscure what it is
um you know most work being done by
origin of life researchers are
done by either biologists or geologists
or chemists
okay the physicists are beginning to
horn in on the game
and physics alone is not going to do it
or math or computer science alone is not
going to do it you're going to need
biology and chemistry and
geology for that matter planetary
science
but there might be some general
principles
that help us understand why life began
not just
the specific exact way that it began
but was it likely was it a rare
fluctuation is it the kind of thing that
happens all the time
these are things that i think are
answerable questions to which right now
we don't have the answers at all
but i think that we're gonna be able to
get there okay the other thing i want to
talk about were
you know some details some technical
details
about power laws
because people correctly asked some
perceptive questions
[Music]
about power law distributions because
you know again this is a little bit
insight into how science goes right um
we say words like power law
distributions but it's a question like
how seriously do you take that like how
much can you extend
the power law across all the different
scales or you know
did you only ever mean it was
approximate or within some regime or
whatever
these are all crucially important
questions that we should uh actually
think about
so think about our power laws again okay
so let's
let's do this on a just a linear plot so
not a log log plot
f of x goes down like this
as a function of x and so this is x to
the
minus n okay and um
we're going to have to do some calculus
okay
let's note one problem right away that
as x goes to zero
f of x blows up if n is a positive
integer a positive number of any sort
then f of x becomes infinite so there's
already a problem which is
um are you telling me there needs to be
an infinite number
of infinitesimally small things in my
power law
and the answer there is well no you're
not really supposed to take it seriously
as
x goes to zero right like maybe at some
value
it begins to be well approximated by a
power law whatever this distribution is
you know city sizes or whatever like if
your
if your distribution is city sizes or
lengths of words or something like that
there is a smaller city size one person
and you know the smallest word one
letter etc so
um this you shouldn't extrapolate beyond
where it makes physical sense to do so
but there's another problem which is you
know what if we wanted to calculate
the average what is the average value of
x
in this power law there's different
notations that people use well let's say
average value of x
well one way to do that is we first need
to do the integral
of f of x right you know get the or
normalize it or something like that
um so when i we talked about doing
integrals before we talked about
calculus
and one of the things i've shielded you
from is
that you know when if if all you knew
about calculus is what you heard in
these videos especially video number two
which was on change
uh you might think that calculus is not
that bad you know some symbols and some
concepts but how hard is it why are
people always complaining
of course if you took a course on
calculus and did problems
then very little of your intellectual
power
is devoted to the concepts and a lot of
it is devoted to the rules for
manipulating
functions and taking their derivatives
and taking their integrals
and those rules and those procedures can
be very complicated okay
so i've saved you from learning all
those rules but now we're going to do
one
i'm just going to do the simplest one
there's for example we talked about the
fact that doing derivatives of functions
is relatively easy
doing integrals of them is relatively
hard but for functions of this form
f of x is x to the minus n it turns out
to be easy
in both cases so if we want if we want
to if we have f
of x equals x to the minus n
what is the derivative of f with respect
to x
well the answer is you take that
exponent in this case minus
n and you pull it down and multiply so
this is
minus n times x
and then you remove one you subtract one
from the exponent so it's x to the
minus n minus one okay
that's it that's the formula that's the
derivative of this function at any one
point
what about the integral so the integral
well
the crucial thing about the integral is
the integral of f of x
dx when you do the integral of a
function
it had better be the opposite of doing
the derivative that is to say
if you do the integral of the derivative
or the derivative of the integral
you better get back the original
function so
if the exponent goes down by one when
you differentiate it better go up by one
when you integrate
so you know that this is going to be
proportional to
x to the minus n plus one
and then you know that if you
differentiate the right hand side
you better get rid of whatever numbers
you have
outside so you're going to bring down
minus n plus 1.
so you better divide by minus n
plus 1. there you go that's the integral
and therefore you can check if you take
this thing on the right hand side
x to the minus n plus one over minus n
plus one and differentiate it
you should get this answer you should
get x to the n minus n
back okay good um except
there's one exception
when you when f of x equals x to the
minus one
when n equals one then looks what look
what happens
uh that's not easy to see what happens
here but when n equals 1 you get x to
the 0 here and sort of you stop this
chain of going down if you just
differentiate differentiate
differentiate or integrate and
integrate you should be able to go up
and down by integers but you can't if
you hit 0 in the exponent at any one
time
so it turns out that the integral of x
to the minus 1
dx so that's n equals 1 in our notation
is the logarithm of x it's a special
case
okay but otherwise this is true so
if you want to know you know what is the
you know how do we normalize this
distribution how do we like take
um the integral over everything here
well
when you integrate here's another trick
for another not a trick a fact about
doing integrals
let's say you integrate between two
numbers let's say this is a
and this is b remember the integral is
the area under the curve
okay so if you integrate between a
and b we write that in this notation
okay you integrate from a to b and
the answer is so in fact let me just
plug in that f of x
equals x to the minus n
well it's this x minus n plus one over
one
so let's write over one over minus n
plus one
but then we plug in x equals b
into this formula and then we subtract
from that what we get we plug in x
equals a
from this formula so we get b to the
minus
n plus 1 minus a
to the minus n plus 1. and one way of
thinking about this
is um i'm not sure if i should i do this
in another color or not
let's see if i can do it another color
i haven't used this magenta yet the
integral
up to b is sort of everything
here and the integral up to a
is sort of everything here
up to a and then you subtract off
the integral up to a from the integral
up to b and you get
just the white area in here which i will
now
i'll make even whiter okay you get just
this area
which is what we want that's what we're
looking for
okay so
that's nice but now let's see what
happens here
um let's take you know if f of f f of x
equals x to the minus n let's take n
equals 2. right
then minus n plus 1
equals minus 1.
so the integral from a to b x to the
minus 2
dx equals one over
minus one so i'm just going to write
that as minus one
one over minus one is minus one i think
we agree
times b to the power of minus one
minus a to the power -1
okay but if you thought you were taking
your
distribution too seriously and let a
go all the way down to 0 then
a to the minus one is infinity and
that's bad right that means that you
know there is no the integral over the
under the curve is infinitely big
and that doesn't sound good that doesn't
that doesn't sound like what we want at
all
uh if it because remember the curve
represents something real the number of
cities or the number of people or
the number of elephants or something
like that so to have it be infinite is
just bad in some way
likewise if you have let's say you know
n equals
uh 0.5
okay so you get a integer below
one then minus n
plus one equals 0.5
okay and your integral
from a to b of x to the minus 0.5
dx equals minus n plus 1 so 0.5
1 over 0.5 in other words
2 times
b to the 0.5
minus a to the 0.5
so okay that's good a can go to zero
zero to zero point five just zero that's
no problem but b
you're supposed to be able to take up to
infinity if you
if you you should be able to if you just
believe this curve for any value of x
and then b infinity to the minus 0.5
power is infinity again
so i still got infinity for the integral
of this function
and finally i'm not going to go into it
but if um
if n were exactly 1 then i would have
this exception
and i would have the integral of x to
the minus 1 dx which is log x
and if i look way back here what the
logarithm does
where's my logarithm function logarithm
is
minus infinity at zero and plus infinity
at plus infinity so it's the worst it's
infinity in both directions
so the point is that these kinds of
curves
are not normalizable there is no such
thing as the total
area under the curve or rather it's
infinite technically you know it's
whatever you want to call that a number
or a limit or whatever it's not just a
finite number
and therefore we can't you know take the
average of it or anything like that
um there is no average value someone
explicitly asked like if i have some
physical thing like avalanches or
meteorites or whatever
described by this power law and i want
to say okay what's the average
i don't think i can get it and the
answer is yes you can't get it there's
no such thing as the average value in
this kind of distribution
so what's going on and what are you
supposed to do about that that's that's
the
question i wanted to address in a very
kind of
slightly unhelpful way but let's do the
log log plot again okay so here's log of
f
versus log of x and we're saying that
okay it's a straight line but you can't
do the integral over the whole thing you
can't find the average
things like that um you can't treat it
too seriously
but the answer is you can't treat it too
seriously that's what the answer is so
remember we in the real world you gotta
keep in mind the difference between the
real world and
spherical cow land okay like the exact
power law
that you extend to x equals zero and x
equal to infinity
is clearly an approximation clearly a
spherical cow clearly ignoring
some important features of the physical
system in the real world you have some
data points remember
and the data points might be very very
well approximated
by a power law but you should know
that you better had better not
extend them too far to the right or to
the left
because whatever were the approximations
that you made
are going to cease to be valid and the
reason why we couldn't do an integral
under this curve why we couldn't
normalize it why we couldn't find the
average
we're not because of what's was not
because of what's going on here
in the power law region but because of
what's going on at the tails you know
either zero or at infinity right
and the answer really is don't take the
rules seriously there
for one reason or another so in real
applications of this kind of way of
thinking about complex systems
you have to not only say i have a power
law but you have to say
between whatever values of
x i can actually verify the power law is
real and i
shouldn't believe it above that or below
it and the reason why that's crucially
important is because as we said before
in the original video here it's very
often the case you know these power laws
have the
property that they feature a lot of
events
or more events than you might want to
believe in at very very large values of
x
right like way more than you would get
with a normal distribution with a
gaussian
even way more than you get with a log
normal or something like that
okay so when you have rare but crucially
important events
pandemics maybe
avalanches solar flares whatever they
are earthquakes
um it's crucially important to know
how far we can extend our belief in this
power law like behavior
to values of the size parameter
that we haven't actually gathered a lot
of data about
that's why you know in recent it's not
why but it is closely related to the
fact
that whether it's climate or
[Music]
pandemics or whatever you might have
noticed
that in recent years the last 10 years
there have been
a lot of events where this is supposed
to be a one in every 100 year event
and how many times how can you get one
in every 100 year events every two years
right well
there's something off about your
extrapolation of the power laws two very
very large
scales so i'm not going to tell you
what the remedy is i'm not going to tell
you how to deal with this other than to
be cautious right
other than to know what your
uncertainties are
to know the uh if any of you happen to
enter into the game of predicting the
stock market or avalanches or whatever
know where to believe your
extrapolations
into unknown territory and know where to
be skeptical of them right
this is just a crucial feature of how to
do science correctly it's just that in
this sort of power law type behavior
it becomes even more necessary
and if you want to know something like
okay for meteorites for avalanches or
whatever what is the average size
um i'm not sure if there's an algorithm
for answering that but my
answer would be try just doing the
calculation
taking the power law seriously where
it's allowed to be taken seriously
and this is something again that's sort
of vaguely reminiscent of what we talked
about with the renormalization group in
other words you put
cutoffs okay and infrared cut off at
large distances and ultraviolet cut off
at small distances
and then you calculate things and
everything is cut off you should get
finite answers for the average
and for you know the total number and
things like that
and then ask yourself do those
quantities depend
sensitively on your cutoffs and if they
don't then it's okay then you've
succeeded then you then it's
it's you've uh found a good reasonable
answer
but if your answers depend a lot on your
cutoffs that means that you don't know
what's going on
you don't really know the true physical
situation it's not quite accurately
being described by this power law that
you have
so i have no more words of wisdom than
that this is a part of the adventure of
doing science that it's fun to push
around the equations it's much harder to
understand the real world
both of them are useful i hope that uh i
hope that over the course of these
videos you've learned a little bit about
both kind of techniques